hey everybody is Jessie and uh happy
Monday
hope everybody had a good weekend at the
end of last week I was working from home
my streams were not not the same quality
in terms of video quality so I could
barely keep 720p I am back now in my
office and so the quality in the stream
should be a lot better today we're going
to work on the masonry layout so at some
point I think last week we we started
working on this and we got to the point
where it was working and it seemed like
that was it
I'll just have to do a few more things
and and it would work but that's not
that's not how it went so I had some
problems so I decided to do a part two
to show those problems and hopefully fix
them today's show is going to be a
little bit shorter than I have been
doing so lately I've been doing really
long shows because the things we've been
trying to get done have been a little
bit more complicated and that's what's
taken a while but I have a meeting at
3:00 3:00 p.m. Eastern Time so in less
than an hour so this definitely has to
be less than an hour so I'll try to cut
it off and start answering questions at
at 2:30 and unless I can get this
working sooner than that I don't know
maybe and then definitely be done you
know before 3:00 so hey everybody you
have some people in the live chat so
how's it going
hopefully the the lag time will be
better - between when I say and do
something and when when you all actually
see it also have some upgrades I got
that new microphone hooked up on my work
machine now so let me know if it doesn't
sound good
I'm hoping that this is better sound
quality than just the mic that comes
with an iMac so if it's not I definitely
want to know and and I can return the
mic and maybe get a better one or just
stick with what I had and oh the other
big piece of exciting news that I have
is I just upgraded my RAM in this iMac
so I have double the RAM so that's
always fun
I've noticed it is slightly faster so
we'll see the real test will be when I
have a million tabs open and we'll see
if it if it still holds up but let me um
let me show you the problem that I'm
having and where'd it go so I had just
at it okay so let me show you the issue
first I got to go in so we're on a
branch so let me do a get check out so
if you're not familiar with git you can
make these branches which are basically
like alternate versions of your of your
app or of your site and you can just
switch between them so they're like
they're like parallel universes and
programming so if you you can try out
some crazy thing on one branch and it
doesn't matter if you totally mess it up
because you switch back to your master
branch and everything is is like it like
it should be and you can use that to
push depending on how your deployment is
you know that could be the branch that's
stable and you actually push out to your
server so I'm going to switch to the
Nathan tree branch
and
now we should be able to see I'm going
to bring up the site on on my other
screen right now bringing it up what
page it resources okay
so here we go here's the page right and
look it looks like masonry is is working
this is what we were left with you know
last week after we got this going but
when I click this tab you can see
definitely not working and this is
actually even worse than what it
normally gives me usually I can at least
get like this layout but the footer is
back here but this time I couldn't even
get that yeah okay so here's what I
normally get something like this so
that's obviously not what we want
and also I haven't tested the images yet
I'm assuming that'll work it talks about
in the documentation for the react
component that we use and this is the
component in case you you aren't
watching what we first started this I'm
using reactive masonry component and
this is a react component that uses the
masonry library of you familiar with
masonry or isotope it's used on a lot of
sites to get you know this kind of kind
of effect you know all these are just
positioned with JavaScript you know so
each one as you move the page around the
position changes so you always have you
know kind of nice even spacing between
everything so the problem is really I
need to refresh the layout somehow when
the tab is clicked and I think I ran
into this issue on a site I did before
but I wasn't using the react what the
react component I was using just masonry
you know just the the JavaScript plug-in
by itself so I had access to you know to
everything that you can do with that so
there was a way to just kind of refresh
things when you when you press the tab
so that's kind of what I need to do at
least what I think will fix this problem
but I haven't been able to figure out
how to do it there's not really at least
on on the documentation here I have not
seen how to do that I did find something
in the if you yeah they have these
triggers so like on image is loaded on
layout complete on remove complete so I
don't really need the trigger I will
need images loaded at some point but I
don't need the trigger what I need is
you know that that refresh so does that
make sense I'm just I'm checking the
live chat just for a second have more
people in here now talking so okay
Sebastian says there's some weird
statics on oh you know what I've forgot
to turn my fan off let me turn the fan
off and see if that helps it's a little
bit warm in here today so hopefully that
that helps it was an oscillating fan so
I imagine when the fan was blowing right
on the mic that probably made the noise
okay saying so it's probably not the fan
it was some other some okay let me
definitely not the fan sir all right so
if it's still happening Oh someone's
saying it was the fan
let me I'm gonna do a little bit more at
least with that mic and just see if it
keeps happening if not if it gets really
bad let me know and then I'll just
switch to the to the internal mic and
yeah I'm not sure it wasn't a really
expensive mic so I read some of the
reviews on Amazon said that it was
better than the internal mic so I
thought I'd give it a shot and we'll see
maybe yeah maybe I need to go with
something a little bit more expensive a
little better quality
okay so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to go to these issues and okay try
I should have I think I still have the
issue open on my laptop and I should
have checked that out layout complete
mmm
it's not it's not exactly what I want to
do to come up with the issues are
I may be able to just look at what tabs
are open on my laptop right now and just
open it from there
there we go so I'm just going to open
the issues from my tabs all right nice
that's a nice feature if you're using
Chrome and you're logged in on multiple
devices you can see what's open on all
of them so on my other screen i just
opened some some of the issues that that
had to do with at least some some what
had to do with the issue that we're
dealing with
okay so this is what let me bring this
over this is what I found that I think
might help so and I couldn't get this to
work maybe late last week I was working
on it and basically you can bind this
instance of masonry and then you can you
should be able to do something like this
you know this masonry on layout complete
then you know do something so I couldn't
get I couldn't get it to the point where
I could bind it and actually access this
it kept telling me you know like this
you know it doesn't exist so let me
check let's go to our code and when the
resources page they make this a bit
bigger for you and I don't really need
this right now and I don't need I need
that side pen all right sit and that'll
give us more space okay so you see we
have mace these components now on just
the first two tabs over the B tab that
has everything and then the tab that
just has the audio cards you know we
have masonry here we're going to try to
add these
we're going to try to add this on one of
them just to see if we can get something
because something going okay then we
should be able to call something like
this so let's just let's just copy this
I know this this isn't exactly what we
want to do right now but this will be a
good first step so I'm just going to go
up here and put actually I already have
component did not so I don't need to
copy the whole thing okay so this
masonry on layout completes let's
alright so I guess we'll do we will put
a layout complete Handler and let's just
do something simple like
all right
let's say that and hopefully hopefully
we'll see that I was just wondering
about with server-side rendering maybe
now that shouldn't worry because well
we'll see who tested here we go back
here and I'm going to respect this we
can see the console and first I want to
click just to see if there's any
difference now if you see whatever tab
that's pretty odd now I'm have I have
these things appearing mm-hmm what did
we do here
that's really weird I'm going to refresh
this because I have never had that I
don't know why that's happening
okay I'm going to check the live chat to
you someone did I put okay
so good so Patrick in the live chat
mentioned I must have that in the in the
JSX where do I have it should be oh
you're right I I must have accidentally
put that oh I know what I did I pressed
the the wrong key when I was trying to
close this pane the command slash like I
guess would be like the backslash I
can't ever remember which ones /e which
was backslash but one of them makes a
comment and the other one toggles this
pain on the side so I press the wrong
one didn't realize that commented that
okay so that fix is that not really our
problem that we're trying to deal with
but good catch on that Patrick thank you
okay I did have a question about what
masonry is but it looks like it got
answered in the live chat so in case you
are just joining a Mason you have a sent
the same question masonry layout is I
mean this this is what it is what it
ends up looking like where you can have
content of differing Heights you can
even have different widths if you wanted
to and then it all lays out nicely with
you see there's always the same space
between them you know on all sides and
it you know it keeps that space no
matter what as you see as we do this our
width and height changes but it's still
it still works so that's basically
masonry layout so and then there's a
JavaScript plug-in cold masonry that
we're also using all right so what I'm
not getting is any any logging from what
we wanted here so we wanted this console
log layout complete handler this little
complete handling okay so this should
have it should have done something well
though now I don't remember when we do I
just want to test this because I'm not
sure with our server-side rendering if I
should even see this on the on the
client side
maybe if I maybe if we do the our
client-side routing and then we'll see
that I'll give it a try either way so
first I'll do a hard refresh and this
should give us the the completely
rendered HTML
it's assuming my I'm gonna just restart
this so I still I know I've said this
several times but I still haven't
figured out what the issue is with why
my dev server just keeps like hanging
it's starting to get pretty annoying so
I think I'll figure it out okay so I did
get let me bring this over here and show
you that I did actually get that console
log so so we can see that that actually
did work so what should have happened is
we should have got those three
exclamation points that are in that are
here layout complete handler I'm just
double-checking that I spelled
everything right yes so this should have
worked because our layout our layout
should have been complete I wonder if
there's some issue with me using two
instances of of masonry let's say let me
uh I'm gonna switch it to this one just
to check you know maybe see for evany
luck with with the first one instead the
second one the the hot module reloading
does some weird things sometimes like
that
okay so I did get it this time so that
week so we got these exclamation points
this time so that's what we wanted I'm
going to click click around here see if
I can get them again show up oops wrong
page we're on resources right there we
go that's why I didn't get it okay so I
did get it again
so both when we do I'm gonna do a hard
refresh double-check that great so
you're client-side routing we still get
this so it based so it works
for some reason though it did not work
when we had it on the second masonry
element that's not good news if you need
to be able to use this multiple times or
else I have to rethink how this is laid
out plan B could be if I need to if I
can't get this to work with with
multiple instances of this masonry
component on the same page then if I
need to all of them could be within one
masonry component and then we could do
some sort of sorting some kind of
sorting where I can pick pick the
categories and they all just all the
cards are just shown in head I don't
know if masonry can do that right off
the bat off to check I know
isotope which is a JavaScript plug-in
built by the same guy that built masonry
isotope does do some cool things with
sorting so I'll check that out isotope
flow is not free to use so may have to
buy buy a license for that and then see
if it works with this with this
component I'm going to see thoughts
actually a bromo Matic says were you
calling both of them this masonry
actually no I was just using one at a
time my next step was going to be okay
do we need to call these different
things yeah I guess that could be the
next step let's see if we can mmm
yeah let's see if we can do something
like that where we just give this a I'm
just going to put two on the end I
probably will not keep that keep that
naming but for now we'll see if it works
all right so let's see what we're gonna
get wow I really need to figure out what
is going on with my Wow
okay all right I can at least see
something I'm still getting this but I'm
not getting that second one and would
force reflow ask you JavaScript alright
so I haven't really seen this happen
before so I'm guessing that whatever I
just did here with this is not gonna
work out yeah I mean it's not like I did
anything different all I did was just
add this in a second time and then up
here yeah just out of this there's
nothing in here that I see that really
should have caused this so let me check
one to another page just to verify that
it's it's something on that page that's
doing it actually maybe it's maybe I do
need to restart the server um all right
we'll try one more time I don't really
have at this point much hope that I can
get both of them working so it may have
to just think of some something else
well I'm okay that should be up map Vlad
asked sublime text sir Adam which
program better to use Thanks I've never
used sublime so I can't really say I do
I like Adam it is I've noticed
Adam is slower than like Visual Studio
code so I can't compare it to sublime
you know myself I've heard that sublimes
a lot faster I mean I like Adam I'm open
to switching to something else though
it's just hard to switch when you have
all your packages set up the way you
want them okay it definitely is that
page so let's take this out then
yeah
all right since since the way that is
given in the documentation to target a
specific component seems like at least
at this point it only works if I put it
on the first instance of this component
then I think I'm this is a dead end that
I'm trying to go down here so need to
switch it and try something else okay so
I'm just going to kind of mess
everything up here
yeah
so since this first instance is really
all I need it'll contain everything
there are reasons that I wanted to split
it out like this one of them being that
there's a limit by default on how many
how many posts you can get back when you
make an API called a WordPress which is
what the all this content is where it's
coming from so I thought it would just
be a lot easier if at some point I could
make separate calls for each one of
these but there are other ways to get
around that and I think that's an easier
problem than trying to dig into this
component and see see what I need to do
so let's
oops I forgot to take out the stuff at
the top and something up here was
messing this up
so hopefully this will work now great
okay so that works now we have
everything here of course these are not
going to work anymore
so what we need to do then is have some
other way of switching these out which I
think we can we can figure that out and
what I put that okay so let me search I
know I saw somebody else pretty sure so
somebody else got a filter select item
just like example there we go I think
that's the one we need it's a little
slow alright
hmm okay so it looks like there's not a
built-in filter like with with isotope
[Music]
all right so here's what I think we'll
have to do then let me check this one as
well who's that one isotope
maybe
so it looks like they do have a branch
that works with isotope
all right let me go back I'm gonna check
the live chat see if anyone has any
ideas
okay brahmam addict says maybe a 1
masonry component and clicking on the
the all audio you know video buttons
will change is the filter inside that
one that one instance yeah I think
that's that's probably what what needs
to happen
okay so
let me look at I want to see what the
JSON looks like here to see what I can
what I can filter by I don't remember
what I called everything so I'm going to
take a look at that
okay I'll bring this over if you can see
what I'm looking at here's our here's
the data that we're getting we're
actually not getting this much I am
narrowing it down a bit you can see
we're getting that up here so we're
making this call here and we're actually
just getting the title and then these
custom fields that we set up
[Music]
so in these custom fields okay so I do
have a field called type so this is what
we need to check for
okay so
let's
so I think I do want them all to show up
at first so that this is going to say
the same this is going to be the first
the first load what's going to happen
then is when we click let's add a click
where's our tabs
oh here there sorry I was looking at the
wrong one this is what we want this is
has all of them here's our tabs so let's
see I'll put a click one click that's
how it is in reactivate it's just it's
on click
I'm checking the live chat just quickly
thoughts there's no idea about front-end
development especially not with react
can't help sorry it's alright mark asks
what is isotope okay so isotope is just
a JavaScript plug-in that sorts out you
can sort out eight HTML elements and
like a grid so think like like Pinterest
like how it's all laid out in a grid
like this so like this but isotope lets
you like let's say I'd click on these
and it would just sort them on the fly
so they would all you know come in and
come out Ries or tan everything really
easily it can do other stuff too but
that's mainly what I've used isotope for
yeah actually Sebastian has a good point
Plan C I can just use masonry
client-side that's actually not that's
not a terrible idea
that's a that might be a good idea I'm
going to take a second to just think
what would be the fastest way so I the
the most to me the best way would be to
me to figure out how to do this like the
react way right with within that context
but a way to do it that would definitely
work and it might it might make sense to
just get this working right now and then
work on the other stuff later on would
be just to use masonry as on its own
without being you know imported you know
via this react nation Airy component and
then then I would have access to
everything
let's just do that because otherwise I
don't think there's any way I'm going to
get this to work right now since I will
since I've never done it before and I've
done the other way before so if I have
any chance of getting this working today
I doesn't have to be working today but
I'd like for it to be working today
then I'm going to go with Sebastian
suggestion so here's what we're going to
do we're going to go to masonry there we
go we're good at lacing website and I'm
going to just pull in everything from
the CDN for now and because that will be
the fastest that way I don't have to
download anything and we can just try it
out and see if it works
so I'm gonna throw this I guess it
doesn't even really matter where I put
this just put it in here let me take out
this react masonry component and let's
take out where we've used masonry here
and let's just make this a div
and I don't even need this div actually
let's just take it out okay so you don't
need that div and okay so we just put on
the column let's crab I think that's it
I think it's all we need let's let's
remove this I'm just trying to get rid
of everything so you don't get any
errors
need that okay um so this is why would I
do
and I need to add these these other
things in as well at some point we need
to add back our categories because we're
going to be able to use the the tabs
like we were hopefully we can get that
to work
so let me I'm just going to copy and
paste on my other monitor I'm just going
to copy and paste from the git repo what
we have on the master branch because
that'll best basically what we need
I either could do that or I could just
hold down you know command Z for like a
minute and it would probably get us back
to where we wanted but I'd still have to
change out the masonry components
okay patrick said there was some audio
static so it for sure was not the fan
which which is what we thought that it
wasn't the fan anyway so I may be
returning this microphone so definitely
don't need the static
all right the microphone I really wanted
was not the one that I got anyway so I
don't know if I can justify buying the
one that I really wanted but I think
it's like a hundred bucks it's not like
an insane amount of money but you know
it's not really necessary I think
everybody could hear me with the
built-in mic all right so we have here's
everything and man that was ugly I kind
of just copied in really really ugly
looking so that's better
okay so let's save that and just verify
that this is working flow oh that's what
was happening
I left that on click in there sorry I'm
just going around really fast I hope I'm
not making anybody like motion sick that
would probably make me motion sick if I
were watching I do I need to keep an eye
on the time and not forget about that I
should have set an alarm but I did not
okay - 42
I can go for maybe about 10 more minutes
it doesn't look like there's really any
any questions as I'm kind of scrolling
around there at least I did answer a few
questions as we were going so so we may
not even really have a kind of question
answer session at the end of this video
like we normally do so doesn't look like
there's any questions if you do have
questions throw them in there now into
the live chat and then that way I know
and I'll I'll try to end early enough so
that I could get to them and as always
if you don't get your question in in the
live chat if you're watching later or
something then you can okay this is it
that this this looks bad but this is
what it should look like then you can
always put it in the comments on the
video or you can
message me on Twitter and I'll answer
you whenever I get a chance so I do
answer everybody all the comments and
everything and any messages anybody
sends me I do answer it sometimes it's a
few days before I can get to it but I
definitely try to answer every question
all right so that's what we want it to
look like right now so now since we've
imported a masonry here now let's
initialize it I don't really want to
initialize it with jQuery even though I
could I'd rather just use vanilla
JavaScript because I'm not I guess I'm
let me grab this element argument if you
finish yeah this is what I need okay so
we'll do it in component did mount um
[Music]
let's call this and then make this
actually do I need to say I probably
need to do that right let me know if
that's the case but I think I do need to
do that now we can paste this in here
and I can change these khans
just to keep it consistent and the query
selector is just going to be row now
yeah it will be it will be wrote because
each one is going to be a tons sorry I'm
thinking out loud here normally you
would have you know one you know one
encompassing element for everything but
in this case we're going to multiple so
yeah it would be row actually I should
just look to save time I did this on a
project where I was using react I'm
pretty sure I was going nearly the same
thing I didn't have four tabs I think I
just did it with two but I should check
that before I try to redo what I would
have already done that would be a waste
of time let me see
and I think that one is a private repo
so if you won't be able to see that one
if you wanted to follow along yeah it is
private but this one that I'm working on
now is public so you can check that out
if you want to links in the description
all right
all right so let me bring this over just
you can see you see what I'm saying let
me go over here this might be a little
small sorry about that but there's a lot
of stuff so I think we need it need to
be able to see most of this okay so I'm
bringing in hmm here we go so I actually
have named I've quoted quite a lot of
things going on here so we have this
container well this kind of looks like a
mess I don't know what I was thinking
probably I think I had a lot of this
from an earlier project that I just
copied in and so this is not all
necessary but it was easy okay so I I do
have the basic structure is pretty much
the same although it looks like I've
kind of messed with the the normal
layout here and the the container for
everything is a column instead of a row
so I don't want to do that again what I
really want to see though is how I've
setup isotope to work here so you see I
do have two of these and it looks like I
just kind of have the container inside
what would this would be my row normally
yeah I don't know why I have this this
stuff nested so deeply but I'm going to
go to I'm going to have to go into the
the JavaScript because I did not put
that in the component let's see
all right let me i see where my uncle is
search okay I think this is it I'm gonna
take this off the screen I just want to
double-check and make sure there's
nothing in this file that should not be
public no I don't think there's
all right so
I might actually be using isotope and
not masonry which is not a huge deal
because they're similar enough but it
looks like I am using as the item
selector the column and is the container
I'm using isotope container so I think
if I just put you know basically the row
here I'll give the row a class and then
as the item use column that should work
yeah so let's do that
and then that'll be that'll probably be
the last thing we could do so we can at
least just see if this works and I don't
know we'll see if okay and you're asked
can we get your github user script phim
so yeah my theme for github is it's the
github dark script and I'm using
tampermonkey to run that so I think it's
not a custom custom script that I did so
if you look up github dark script
I think there's instructions for how to
use it in different browsers with
different plugins so check that out it's
really cool there's also lots of options
you can customize it if you want I'm
just using the base here the default
options right now all right so let's do
let's give these rows
let's go so make a masonry containers
and then I think we should be good
within that to say that the just the
columns so with this to be masonry
container and then this one is going to
be the column okay let's see what
happens when we do that let's let me try
to refresh no I really need to think
just fix this this dev server and figure
out why it's not I've never had this
happen on any other sites that I've used
next to build this is the first time
this has happened so I'm not not really
sure what's going on okay okay so
something's happened this isn't exactly
what I want so I'm going to have to work
on it a bit now you know I don't want
this I obviously want this in four
columns but we can see it's not working
on that
maybe it's just working on the first one
alright so it's definitely it looks like
it it's doing something on the first one
and we'll verify this by inspecting it
and checking out ya the positioning so
we can see like it's being positioned
here so that's it let's see if it's
doing it on any other tabs it might not
be I might have to hmm
yeah so well yeah definitely need some
work but at least we got it to
initialize we just need to work on the
to some of the settings that we can use
so basically I don't know if I'll do a
part 3 to this I might just do it it
looks like there's not like a ton of
interest in this at least let me know if
I'm wrong here but just based on like
the number of viewers we're getting it's
a little bit lower than normal so I'm
wondering I mean maybe it's just Monday
everybody's busy but maybe there's just
not a lot of interest in this topic so
maybe there might not be a part three
maybe I might just I'll just get it
working and then if you're interested
you can check out the the repo and ask
me questions if you want to but
basically if you were going to do this
here under the next steps the next step
would simply be to riff so first of all
I'll probably need to add another like a
container element or something because
these columns are getting messed up I
need to keep these column classes or I
need to somehow I need to set the
columns correctly like like I can't have
this column width here
I should never left that in so I need to
set it so that it respects oh cool
there we go so just fix that I guess I
needed to respect the columns that we
had that looks nice that's actually
working so so that's that's great so
basically all you need to do now is just
put some click handlers on each one of
those tabs these these tabs here and
then each time a click happens yeah see
that's not that's not work sheesh on the
click happens it would then kind of
Rhian it refresh what's going on with
[Music]
with masonry alright so we'll have to
redo kind of like this thing for each
one of these on click so worst case
scenario it actually destroyed
the first instance of it and then rien
it's on this one and then gets destroyed
so I don't know hopefully I can just do
like a refresh but that's probably what
needs to be done off to check the docs
again it's been a while since I looked
at the docs for masonry
but that's the process so that's what
I'm going to try and that's what I'll
work on probably tomorrow morning so let
me check quickly and see if there's any
questions here at the bottom and then I
gotta go go to my meeting at 3 o'clock
which is in four minutes
luckily the meeting is just like like 10
feet from my door
uh Mark Twain asks have you ever used
google metadata in your project is that
an improvement for SEO I'm not sure
Google meant
I probably won't be able to explain this
I don't have enough time because I need
to ask what you mean do you mean just
like the normal metadata like title tag
and description SEO description or like
the actual meta tags I don't use like
the meta like the keywords I don't use
those at all I don't think they have any
benefits SEO anymore but title tags
definitely have a big benefit
descriptions don't really benefit your
ranking but it's good for like actual
humans when they read that and see
yeah bromo Matic says we should totally
do with the react way yeah I definitely
do want to do it the react way I'd
really love to get it working like that
so probably I can do it like I think I
can do it the react way with with
masonry I can like import it probably
what I should do is like install it with
NPM and then import it into my component
and then set things up like that so I
think I could do it in a more react
friendly way that I'm doing it right now
but it's not like it's not terrible
right now I think it's going to work we
just don't
okay so Bastian says it's kind of
pointless to make another live stream
just to add that on click thing so the
git link for this project is in the
description for this video bromo Matic
says you can bring back the masonry
component add filter prop to the
internal state update filter value you
have to click on the tabs and you could
use something like string match inside
the filter alright I'm definitely going
to check that out and take a look at it
I got to go to my meeting right now
though thanks for watching and I'll be
back tomorrow 2 p.m.